und dazu begrüßen wir jetzt bei uns im
Studio Bild tv-chefredakteur Klaus
Strunz schönen guten Tag Klaus guten Tag
Bild hat es immer gefordert die AKW
Wende und sie kommt jetzt Robert Habeck
zieht die Reißleine zumindest vorerst
bis Mitte April sollen die weiterlaufen
warum erst jetzt und welches Signal
sendet Robert Habeck damit naja erstmal
die gute Nachricht ist dass er es tut
denn er muss ja einen wesentlichen Teil
seiner gesamten politischen Biografie
einen wesentlichen Aspekt der gesamten
politischen Ideologie der Grünen über
Bord werfen um zu dieser Entscheidung zu
kommen das hat er getan das nötigt mir
Respekt ab wir kommen da vielleicht
gleich noch dazu was deswegen persönlich
bedeutet aber er hat es natürlich sehr
sehr spät getan denn
viele vernünftige Leute sagen ja schon
seit Monaten dass das der richtige Weg
gewesen wäre und der hat jetzt im Grunde
zu Lasten der Bürger in Deutschland
Zeit verloren und dadurch haben wir
Energie verloren dadurch werden wir in
die Schwierigkeiten kommen
die prognostiziert sind und die hätten
wir lindern können wenn Habeck schneller
reagiert das ist ja oft so einer macht
irgendwas nicht wird der kritisiert dann
macht er es doch aber zu spät wird er
kritisiert damit muss er jetzt umgehen
du hast die Zeit schon angesprochen der
Ausstieg vom Ausstieg aber nur für drei
Monate ist nicht jetzt schon klar dass
das nicht reichen wird dass wir damit
nicht durch die Krise kommen werden also
wer eins und eins zusammenzählen kann
wird zu dem Ergebnis kommen ich hoffe
der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister kann eins und
eins zusammenzählen und er braucht halt
dauernd irgendwelche Begründungen warum
es jetzt doch macht die Begründung kann
nicht sein Pragmatismus hey Leute das
müssen wir jetzt machen weil es geht um
Deutschland es geht um die Menschen es
geht um die
Wärmeerzeugung es geht um den Strom das
müssen wir jetzt machen ich setze jetzt
Pragmatismus über Ideologie sondern er
braucht immer er sehnt sich förmlich
nach externen Begründungen die zum Teil
bizarre sind also sich jetzt auf
Frankreich zu beziehen ist bizarr sich
darauf zu beziehen dass es nur wenig
dazu beiträgt uns besser zu stellen war
das war ja dauernd sein Argument aber
wenn etwas wenig hilft hilft es ja
wenigstens schon mal man merkt wie wie
hoch die Hürde ist über die da drüber
muss und ich kann das verstehen und
nachvollziehen denn die Hürde ist nichts
weniger als sein Lebenswerk und nichts
weniger als die daseinsbegründung der
Grünen an sich das heißt es geht
wirklich um viel du sagst es der grüne
Wirtschaftsminister liegt die Grünen
Ideologie erstmal auf Eis in
Niedersachsen stehen Wahlen an und dort
in Gorleben in Niedersachsen hat ja auch
der Widerstand gegen die Atomkraftwerke
1 begonnen was bedeutet das für Robert
Habeck persönlich und auch für die
Partei der Grünen und wie durch ein
Wunder läuft dort kein AKW weiter
wundert man sich doch irgendwie haha nur
zwei drei werden besser als zwei muss
man ihm auch ganz klar zurufen das lässt
er jetzt aus aber auf die Begründung bin
ich wirklich gespannt ob die
durchzuhalten ist bis zum 9 Oktober da
ist die Wahl in Niedersachsen und die
Grünen machen dort einen ganz klaren
anti-agw-wahlkampf
alles klar klipp und klar keine
Ausnahmen da freue ich mich auf seine
Wahlkampfauftritte in Niedersachsen wenn
er dann rüber klären muss warum das eine
so und das andere so ist ich kann es
nicht verstehen wenn muss man dann schon
wenn schon denn schon machen denn sonst
macht man sich unglaubwürdig und da ist
sie wieder diese Zerrissenheit ist
Robert habecks er selber wird wissen
dass für ihn auf dem Spiel steht wird er
womöglich am Höhepunkt seiner Karriere
im Ministerium das Kanzleramt vor Augen
wird er womöglich in diesem Moment zum
Totengräber der Grünen weil von ihnen
nach dieser Regierungszeit nur übrig
bleibt sie waren gegen AKWs und haben
sie weiterlaufen lassen sie wollten
Frieden schaffen ohne Waffen und
Deutschland hat angeführt von der
Außenministerin meine grüne Frau
baerbock Waffen geliefert in ein
Kriegsgebiet ein absolutes No-Go wenn
man nur ein bisschen grünes Blut in den
Haaren hat wenn das alles geschreddert
ist was bleibt dann nach dieser
Regierungszeit eigentlich von dem grünen
schwierig was nicht die anderen Parteien
auch längst in ihrem Programm haben also
hier geht es tatsächlich um die Existenz
der Grünen das spürt man Robert habe ich
an und ich habe das Gefühl wenn man ihn
sieht sieht man es ihm sogar an wenn er
das steht und die Dinge verkündet die
ihm gegen den Strich gegen die Biografie
gegen die Ideologie und gegen die
Daseinsberechtigung seiner Partei gehen
das ist schon bemerkenswerter Vorgang
heißt was glaubst du wie geht's für ihn
weiter wie geht es für die Grünen weiter
naja also jetzt müssen sie das ja
erstmal durchziehen dann müssen sie
jetzt all denen die Atomkraft sowieso
für eine vernünftige
energieerzeugungsform in Deutschland
halten ganz ungeachtet der
abschaltungsstrategie die uns Frau
Merkel eingebrockt hat den müssen sie
dann erstmal erklären warum man die
jetzt dann doch abschaltet obwohl sie
doch genutzt haben und dann müssen sie
erklären wie ihr seltsamer Energie Mix
mit Windrädern und Solar eigentlich
normalerweise reichen soll das habe ich
bis heute nicht verstanden wie man sagen
kann wir setzen auf Elektroautos die
lasst mich kurz nachdenken mit nicht
funktionieren mit Strom aber setzt nicht
auf einen einen großen
stromerzeugungsbetrieb wie Atom also für
mich geht diese ganze Philosophie und
diese ganze Idee nicht auf oder sagen
wir es etwas milder jedenfalls nicht in
dem Zeitraum dem die Grünen sich dafür
vorgenommen haben und das ist etwas was
sie wiederum mit anderen Parteien
gemeint haben denn es gibt ja eigentlich
gar keine Partei mehr die sagt wir
müssen an all dem alten festhalten und
das Fahren nur Stinker durch die Straßen
und so weiter und zwar das gibt's ja
nicht mehr das heißt sie kommen in einen
Terrain wo sich andere große tummeln und
wo Menschen vielleicht sagen naja wenn
warum soll ich eigentlich das Original
noch wählen wenn die Kopie schon viel
Überzeugung der besseren größer ist das
steht auf dem Spiel ist eine sehr
unkomfortable Situation und die große
Frage ist natürlich wie soll es dann im
April weitergehen weil du hast die
alternativen angesprochen bis dahin ist
nicht mehr viel Zeit glaubst du dass es
eine Verlängerung von der Verlängerung
über den April hinaus geben wird da bin
ich mir ganz sicher und zwar weil diese
und die Reaktionen darauf doch jetzt
offen legen dass all dieses grüne wie
soll ich sagen
naiv grüne
zukunftsgemälde
in einer stresste in einer
Krisensituation nichts wert ist also
weder kann man Frieden schaffen ohne
Waffen wie man sehen kann noch kann
Deutschland ohne Atomkraft Energie
sicher in die Zukunft gehen das ist ja
das begreift der jetzt Erstklässler und
es werden auch die Wähler begreifen und
nur die ganz ganz überzeugt ich kann
nicht umdenken wir müssen durchziehen
wofür wir immer waren werden dann noch
auf Kurs sein und es werden zu wenig
sein also ich glaube von dem grünen
bleibt am Ende der Regierungszeit eine
Partei die gelernt hat dass Politik
machen was für erwachsen ist
herzlichen Dank Bild tv-chefredakteur
Klaus Strutz
[Musik]